(man) The sharks are back,
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
I'm not trying to make friends.
I'm trying to make money.
We can dramatically
increase profit.
If the sharks
hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
They're so greedy.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I feel this Barbara crap.
I've worked with him.
He's miserable.
You're a vicious granny.
I'm not vicious at all.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
I don't think
you have a clue
about what you're going to do
to run your business.
You have no business concept.
It's sink...
you're getting your ass
kicked in here.
Or swim.
Any side effect?
Diarrhea.
Ooh!
Ha!
You guys don't make it easy,
do you?
Welcome to the "Shark Tank."
♪♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from working
as a waitress in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real estate empire.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
Who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
(man)
First in is Drew Beaumier,
with his idea of the next
generation of costumes.
Oh, lord.
Are they people?
(whirring)
HA!
Ooh!
Hello, sharks.
My name is Drew Beaumier.
My product is drive suits,
and I'm requesting $150,000
for 20% equity stake
in my company.
Drive suits are
the first generation
of wearable
recreational devices
and are unlike any other
product available
on the market today.
Their main attraction
is the function
to instantaneously
transform the user
from a human or walking state
to a vehicular
or motor-driven form.
(laughs)
Crazy.
Whether I'm
at a national convention
or simply testing a prototype
out on the street,
everyone stops,
and the first thing
they always ask me is,
"where can I get one?"
This leads me to believe
that the highest financial
payoff for my invention
exists in mass manufacturing
and distribution.
With your much-needed
investment
and equally needed and respected
business expertise,
I see absolutely no reason
why together
we can't mark a new standard
in children's entertainment
and create a product
that literally
drives off the shelves.
(whirring)
That's cool.
(laughs)
Thank you very much.
How fast does it go?
It goes about 10, uh,
maybe 12 miles an hour.
Drew, can I see it? Can I--
absolutely.
(Barbara) Drew, how did you
come up with the idea?
Um, just basically I needed
to make my rent money,
and I just kind of had
this idea.
I saw a flier
for a costume contest.
And I saw a chance to, like,
definitely make my money back,
my investment back,
even if it was just
selling the costume
after I created it.
Can I ask you a question?
I'm sorry.
Absolutely.
So... I get you put it on.
Mm-Hmm.
Then how do you go?
It's a hand switch.
(whirs)
OHH!
(laughs)
Oh, that's cool.
And it's--
I know it's mechanical
and technological-Looking,
but honestly, all it is
is a positive/negative wire
to a battery with a switch.
Is that insurable?
I actually think these
are safer
than most, uh, like,
standing apparatuses.
Because you're so close
to the ground,
you can't fall, yeah.
How big is the box
that you ship this in?
I have not, uh, yet
begun selling them.
♪♪♪
I was pretty much advised
to not sell
until I had everything
covered with patenting.
What do you want
the $150,000 for?
I believe that's
the minimal amount
I would need to bring
my product to the next level,
which is basically having
an autocad drawing,
all patents, and getting
a manufacturer's request.
Tell us about what it takes
to build one--
You know, what the pieces are,
and then also go into
the patents you're trying
to put together.
They're basically made out
of currently successful
children's products and toys.
Have you been to toy fair yet?
I haven't.
I-I mostly work in, like,
costume contests
And, uh, performances
and appearances.
In the past two years,
we've won about five contests
and I made about $25,000
in cash and prizes.
But, Drew, isn't it time,
at this point,
to partner with
one of the big toy companies,
because so much of the challenge
you face is manufacturing,
which they have nailed down,
and more importantly,
distribution?
What you're wearing
could probably be dumbed down
to a $99 price point,
I would hope,
and perhaps packaged in a way
that would fit on the shelves
of walmart.
If you had... a partner.
(Robert) But what's proprietary
about it, Kevin?
Like, he goes
to a toy company.
Wh-What's unique?
What can't they copy?
Basically, what I have to
bring to the table for them
is just the trial and error
over the past two years.
These are definitely not
the first prototypes.
So it's your experience?
Yes.
The best thing I have in place
is I have the trademark
for drive suits.
I have not been able
to afford a patent.
I had a provisional patent,
which expired,
but I didn't see it doing
much good.
Whoa. Don't like that.
You know what?
These guys are wasting time.
I call these guys hammerheads,
'cause they think
that everything that
walks in the door is a nail,
and they just try
to pound 'em.
Because it works, Mark,
that's why.
You--It doesn't work.
You guys--You guys aren't
about--look.
You guys aren't about
a product yet. So you've got--
what are they about?
You guys have gone
and you've won all this money
at costume parties.
Tell me how much money
you've made,
what you've been
hired to do.
My daily rate is usually--
for a costume,
for an 8-hour day, is I usually
charge $300 or $400.
That's it?
Oh, my gosh.
That's...
that's nothing.
Way too low.
Wha-What is it you want?
You want to be a circus
performer, or you want to sell
500,000 units
through the toy chains?
That's what I would
like to do.
Like I said, I'd much rather
mass manufacture them and--
Okay, so you need
a partner to do that.
Absolutely.
So why wouldn't you
take this to a toy company,
partner with them?
They're currently paying
between 5% and 7% in royalties.
You'd make some money,
my friend.
Sir.
(Mark) what they're really
gonna say is,
"It's not quite ready.
"We're not gonna pay you
7% of anything right now,
"because there's nothing
to pay.
"We're not gonna pay you
an upfront fee.
"and, oh, by the way,
even if we like it,
we're gonna take six months
to put together a contract,"
and meanwhile you're
sitting around doing nothing.
So, Mark, you want to send
this guy into a destiny
of being a circus performer?
(Robert)
Here--Here's my challenge.
You want to manufacture these.
As we've decided,
this is one of the rare times
I think unless you have
a patent
or some proprietary
technology,
you're gonna be in trouble.
I'm out.
Thank you.
So, Drew, it's just
so soon for me,
because there's so many
mysteries right now
with how much it's gonna cost,
where you're gonna make it,
how you're gonna ship it.
I'm sorry, but I'm out.
Okay.
I'm very concerned about
the liability issue,
because I have kids,
and seeing my kids
on the streets with this,
I think I'd be
sick with worry, honestly.
For that reason, I'm out.
Thank you.
Three sharks are out.
Mark and Kevin are
drew's last chance at a deal.
I like the business.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
Using this $150,000,
we're gonna make
20 of these.
Okay.
And then we'll work
with costume designers
to create different looks.
And we'll go out
and we'll have some fun,
and we'll make it viral,
we'll put it online.
(groans)
We'll also hire
an engineer
to help you optimize
the design of this.
We'll see where we can take it
in terms of cost.
Then we'll make some
business decisions.
Because the key here,
you have to understand--
You're not a company yet.
(Daymond) So, Cuban wants you
to work for him
and suck your blood
for about three years...
(Barbara laughs)
Until maybe there's, uh...
that's true.
Some kind of commercial use,
and then he'll--
No, that's not--
That's so far from the truth.
As an elephant in a circus.
You might get a feed bag.
No. That's so far from
the truth, and you know it.
So if we can agree that
there's some uncertainty
and we'll learn as we go
and we'll make some
business decisions as we go,
then I'll offer you
$150,000 in cash
for 40% of the company.
Thank you very much
for your offer.
I don't like to think
small like that.
I don't want to put you
in a circus with a cattle prod
and keep blasting you.
(laughs)
I want to go big.
I think big.
Okay.
I would give you $150,000
for 30% of the company,
with one contingency--
I bring it to the toy company.
They're either gonna love it
or they're gonna hate it.
So the risk you've got
with my deal is,
they simply don't think
there's an opportunity for it.
You know, I sold my company
to a toy company.
I know all the toy company
C.E.O.S.
Look, Drew, two things
that are absolute.
One--With my deal,
you have cash in hand.
Period, end of story.
Two--there's no toy company
that won't take my call.
Question--is that
the right thing to do?
I mean, there's no question
mine's the better offer.
You're either gonna be
an elephant
or you're gonna be rich.
You have two paths.
What are you going to do?
♪♪♪
Drew has two offers
on the table--
$150,000 for 40% of his company
from Mark Cuban.
Kevin's offer is $150,000
for 30%,
contingent on a deal
with a toy company.
♪♪♪
(Kevin) Drew,
isn't it time at this point
to partner with one
of the big toy companies?
We'll either get a deal or not.
The beauty is,
I know how to negotiate it,
and you will either be
in a partnership
with a toy company right away,
or you won't be.
And you'll either be
very rich,
or you'll work for Mark
as an elephant.
Look, Drew, the idea
of trying to sell
to toy manufacturers
is ridiculous.
You don't want it to go
to license to them.
You want to build buzz,
we put it online,
we create a big viral buzz,
and we start building
a business that way.
It may not get as huge
right away,
But if it clicks...
(snaps fingers)
It could get real big.
You know, I'm not trying
to make friends, drew.
I'm trying to make money,
and I think you should
get in tune with that.
Be one with the dollar.
You guys don't make it easy,
do you? (laughs)
(sighs)
Welcome to the "Shark Tank."
I have no problem with
waiting something out
and building it slowly
and taking baby steps...
but I'm kind of a gambler.
Kevin, would you
work with me, please?
(Daymond laughing)
Oh, my god.
(Barbara)
God, what a mistake.
(Daymond) Oh!
That's great, my friend.
Let's try and make it happen.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
You lost to Mr. Wonderful!
(laughs)
(whirring)
He made the biggest mistake
of any entrepreneur
who's ever come in here.
He came out zero sum game.
Every entrepreneur has to
take a chance, Mark, and he did.
Say "cheese."
I'm taking a picture, man.
(camera shutter clicks)
And sharing it with the world.
Don't do that.
Ah, it's too late, baby.
I got my t-Mobile
super-Fast 4g.
Oh, yeah.
♪♪♪
In season one,
Jeff Cohen first walked away
from a million-Dollar offer
from Kevin O'Leary
for his foldable guitar
company, voyage-Air.
I won't give up 51%.
Why?
'cause I'm not gonna
give up control.
You're your own worst enemy!
Last season,
he returned to the tank
and finally sealed a deal
with Kevin.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
♪♪♪
(Kevin) Jeff finally
came to his senses,
and, boy, is he lucky he did.
'cause I've brought him here
to Fender guitar,
the most iconic brand
in the world of guitars.
(whirring)
gentlemen.
Hey, guys.
Richard, good to see you.
Let me introduce you to Jeff.
(Kevin) This is
Jeff's chance to pitch
his folding neck
technology.
The Fender executives,
with my connections
and his great product--
This is
a fantastic opportunity.
It has voyage-air
hinge technology
built into your guitar,
and all we do is
we pop it into place,
and now you have
the very first
Fender voyage-air guitar.
Folding Fender.
Wow.
(playing blues, strumming)
Yeah!
(laughter)
Pretty nice.
Let's try it.
We can talk to
five or ten dealers,
in, uh, various parts
of the country.
We could do 150 guitars.
I'm pretty excited
about this opportunity.
Got a deal?
You got a deal, sir.
All right. Fender's agreed
to do a test
of 150 folding neck guitars
in 5 to 10 stores.
To quote Mr. Wonderful, we're
all gonna make a lot of money.
(playing blues)
(laughter)
♪♪♪
Next up is David Cox,
with a business aimed
at educating baby boomers.
♪♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My name is David A. Cox.
I am the C.E.O. And founder
of pc classes online.
I am seeking $150,000
in exchange
for 15% equity
in my business.
For two years, I managed
an Apple computers dealer
in Cape Cod, Massachusetts,
where I taught
basic computer classes
to the general public.
These classes exploded
in popularity.
And one day,
I was teaching a class,
and I looked out
into the audience,
and I discovered something.
Every single person
in that audience
was over the age of 50.
I had my "Aha!" moment.
There is a massive demand
in this world
for someone who can
teach technology
to the 50-plus crowd.
And here to help explain
and demo our service,
I have with me
our new student,
the one and only
Bruce Vilanch.
♪♪♪
Ha!
Hello, sharks.
(Barbara laughs)
Kevin, thank you
for borrowing the shirt.
(laughing)
Sharks,
pretend that Bruce here
is settled in the comfort
of his own home.
He has just signed up
for our service.
He's gonna immediately
start to receive
our online newsletters,
which contain a list
of all of the classes,
and all the times
each class is offered.
(presses key)
So, Bruce,
we've just finished
our intro to photoshop class.
I have a problem.
There's a-a photo
that I want to send out of me,
and it's flawless.
It's--It's the "Mona Lisa."
(laughs)
Well, there's one tiny flaw.
There's a zit.
It's not a tiny zit.
It's Mount St. Zit.
Oh, my god,
is that hideous!
I know.
(laughter)
All we do is we take
this little tool here--
It's called the lasso.
And we're just gonna circle
that sucker right there.
Hold shift, tap delete...
okay.
Enter, and voila.
Your pimple is no more.
Oh, my... yikes.
(laughter)
Sharks, we want to get
pc classes online
into the hands
of every computer
and gadget retailer.
By bundling our service
with their hardware sales,
we can dramatically
increase both of our profit.
David, how did you meet Bruce?
He taught my mother to skype.
Now I can't get rid of her.
(laughing)
I turn on the computer,
there she is.
(laughter)
Why are you bundling
your sales
with hardware sales?
What's your logic
behind that?
Both of my parents
are therapists,
and they taught me
a very interesting
basic rule in psychology,
that if you can touch it,
it's real.
So instead of just saying,
"Hey, why don't you
buy these classes?",
by putting it
in their hands,
they can touch it.
It makes it real.
We sell our service
for $199 a year.
And through the retailer,
we sell it to them at $99.
They're getting 100% markup.
So you don't want a bundle.
You want it to be sold
as an add-On?
Yes.
You don't even know
what you want.
You don't even understand
the difference
between a bundle
and an add-on.
A bundle is when you
put together two products
or services for one price.
An add-on is something
you add to in a sale
afterwards for more money.
You don't even get that.
You're a bozo.
Do you have any sales?
We've only been in existence
for six months,
but we have about
115 members.
How much did it come to
in revenue?
We're currently, uh,
right around thirty--
$35,000.
(sighs)
Let's say I go
to a large manufacturer
and I say, "bundle this
into a million laptops."
Mm-hmm.
You don't have the capacity
to service them.
You'd blow up in two seconds.
If it was that many,
we would have to expand
rapidly.
You think? (laughs)
(laughs)
We do not pay our teachers,
because what we offer them
is at the end of teaching
a class, the teacher can say,
"if you'd like to do
a private lesson,
here's how you can
sign up for it."
You need slave grunts
that work for free initially,
and then you hope that some
percentage of those individuals
end up getting
a direct relationship
with your customers,
and you get a piece of it?
We get 30%.
You are valuing this business
at $1 million.
Okay. So, is there anything else
that you can tell me
that's gonna give me
the "Aha!" moment
that it's worth
a million dollars?
What it comes down to
is passion.
Mmm.
Ha!
Oh, no, no, no. I--
that's such a huge--
You're the only person
that has passion.
That's such a differentiator.
I want to hear this one!
Thank god we finally found
somebody with passion.
(Mark)
I got to tell you, David.
I used to write for
"Computer reseller news,"
so I'm very familiar...
I love the idea
of classes online...
in 1985.
It's been done again
and again and again.
And to come in as
your differentiation being
50 years old, yet you haven't
said a single, solitary word
about what you're going to do
to identify
50-plus-year-old consumers,
and you've got bundling
confused
with up-sell at retailers.
I don't think you have
a single, solitary clue
about what you're going to do
to run your business.
Now you may think
I'm gonna go out
after saying all that...
and you would be right.
I'm out.
(laughter)
Dave, there's no market
for this.
115 users.
$35,000 in sales.
As an investment,
you're about, uh,
30 years too late. I'm out.
What I think is so remarkable
if you've got people
doing this for free for you.
You're basically
a online computer pimp.
And believe me, David,
it's not worth
a million dollars.
I'm out.
Dave, there's three sharks
that are out.
Mm-Hmm.
David, horrible idea,
horrible pitch,
horrible valuation.
I'm out.
It's all right.
Thank you.
Well, unlike the other sharks,
I think there is a need
for live classes
to the 50-plus crowd.
And this isn't it.
I don't know
if this is it or not,
but I think you've got
to do it from the ground up
and get some traction.
So, with that, I'm out.
Thank you, everyone.
I appreciate your time.
David, you made us laugh.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Come on, let's get sushi.
(laughter)
Thanks, Bruce.
Humor battles everything.
Yeah, because
that idea sucked.
He was terrible.
I don't think so.
I think Bruce
just wanted to meet Barbara.
He's my type.
Sharks, you ripped me
a new one.
It was brutal.
But I still love you.
♪♪♪
Next up is Bill Lyons,
with a web site
to help win
in the real estate game.
♪♪♪
Sharks, I'm Bill Lyons,
and my business is revestor,
the real estate search engine
of the future.
Today, I'm seeking $250,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my company.
Revestor's doing
for real estate
what the internet's done
for car buying
and stock trading.
Revestor gives you access
to information
that only investors
have had up until now.
Say you're a first-time
home buyer.
You want to make sure
you're doing everything
the right way, but you
also want all the answers...
(snaps fingers)
Instantly at your fingertips
so you can figure it out
for yourself.
Mr. Wonderful...
I'm here.
Let's say you're
a real estate investor...
I am.
And you want one thing--
To make money.
The most money possible.
And you know one of the hardest
things to do in the first place
is to find deals.
Go on.
Let me give you a quick tour
and show you how it works.
You go to the home page
and you simply tell it
what kind of property
you're looking for.
Then it tells you
which properties
have the most potential
in a map and list view.
You can then go
to the detail page,
and it gives you all the key
real estate indicators
that are associated
with the property.
It's so easy to use,
anyone can do it.
For example, mark,
Barbara, Robert,
let's say that you all
recently bought similar homes.
What you don't know
is that house "a"
has the potential
to make money.
House "B" is gonna break even.
House "C," unfortunately,
is upside down and underwater.
Question is, which one of you
bought house "C"?
So, Bill, how do you predict
the value of a house
five years from now?
Well, our proprietary
algorithm
makes some assumptions,
but obviously
it's up to the user
to decide
what they believe--
(Robert) Tell me about
the proprietary algorithm
that you use.
Like, what criteria do you use
to come up with the best deal?
The--the patent
is submitted on the fact
that we have the ability
to generate and search
by key real estate
indicators.
Like what?
Where are you
getting the data from?
(Robert) Like what?
Just the same source
Everybody else has?
We-We're partnered
with the largest
listing distributor
in the United States.
Which is?
Listhub and point2.
Oh, there are so many of them.
I thought, Bill,
when you came out here
you were gonna say, "look,
"the world has a huge problem.
"It's full of blood-sucking
real estate agents
Like Barbara..."
(laughter)
"Who suck out all the profits
in their transaction fees
"up-Front--3% to 6%,
so I'm already underwater
when I buy a house."
If you could solve
that problem,
get rid of the barbaras
of the world,
then you'd have something.
Get me directly
to the buyer, maybe,
so I don't have to get
all of that value
sucked out by Barbara.
We still need Barbara
as an expert...
no, we don't.
We gotta get rid of her.
But we don't trust
the barbaras.
We never need Barbara.
We don't trust
the barbaras, right?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Stop using "Barbara."
Sorry.
(Barbara) I feel I'm missing
something basic here.
Okay.
I'm an investor.
I want to buy in Los Angeles.
I have $400,000 to spend,
and I have 30% down.
How are you going to locate
the best house,
not being a fortune-Teller,
knowing what's going to happen
in the L.A. market
over the next two years,
three years, five years?
How are you able to make
a prediction on value?
Best question--
I don't understand
what your magic sauce is here.
Best question so far.
It--It gives you
key indicators
that are associated
with the property to see--
Like what?!
for example? For example?
For example, cash flow,
cap rate,
return on investment.
That's a spreadsheet.
It--
Buddy, I can calculate that
on my own.
No, we're not cut-And-Pasting
a spreadsheet online.
That's not what we're doing.
We're giv--
So what are you doing?
We're giving people "a"--
house "a," "B," "C"--
Which is better?
What's the value of that?
I want to stop them
from ripping you apart,
so maybe I can help you.
(chuckles) Thank you.
Do you have any sales?
We're in ten cities so far.
Our revenue model's
not rolled out yet.
I'm not here to mess around
and make a few thousand bucks.
I want to be one of the largest
real estate web sites,
do $100 million in revenue,
and be a billion-dollar company.
I've done this before.
I'm not a "wantrepreneur."
I've been around
the block before.
Okay, what did you do before?
I built a $20 million company
from scratch.
What kind of company was it
and what did you do?
It was a financial services
company.
(Kevin) Really?
And what did you do?
That's my area.
What did it do?
We're mortgage, real estate,
and life insurance.
I know that business very well.
And what happened?
2007, all of our lenders
stopped funding deals,
and it--It was horrible.
I lost $1 million in a day.
Okay. You know something
about this business.
But why couldn't you use
your software to predict that?
(laughs) The software
didn't exist then.
(Kevin)
What you haven't said is,
"here's my model
and how I make revenue."
Okay, I'm interested.
I want to buy a home in l.A.
How do you make money
for me?
Okay.
So right now maybe you're
going to a foreclosure
Web site...
yes.
To get auction data,
and you're spending
50 bucks a month for that.
Here, you can get the M.L.S.
And the auction data.
The auction sites just give you
the date and the time
of the auction.
So I buy the subscription
for $49.95 a month?
$99.
Because--
$99 a month?
Because you're getting both.
You're getting the m.L.S. Data
and the foreclosure
auction data...
okay.
I'm analyzing it for you.
(snaps fingers)
I'm gonna instantly give you
the deals in your criteria
in your e-mail every day.
So you're really going--
You're not going after
the one-Time buyer.
You're going after somebody
who's investing in real estate,
which is a subset of
the real estate buyer market.
You're almost a service entity
for a very small vertical
of financial buyers.
The normal home buyer
that buys
$5 million properties--
Residential properties--
No, no, you're confusing me.
Is it for the normal couple
that's going out to buy a home,
or is it for the shark
out there
who wants to get
a foreclosure property
and rent it out or flip it?
Which is your audience?
I-It's for both,
because people
are scared to buy.
They want more information.
Bill, you're only gonna
have that person--
Bill, you're talking out of
both sides of your mouth.
It's incredible.
Okay, Bill, let me see if I
get it, and maybe that'll help.
Okay. Okay. Thank you.
So you're buying the data
from the two sources.
Right.
That gives you
M.L.S. listings,
the listings of all the houses
that are for sale,
plus another source that's
giving you the auction listings.
Right.
Right. And you'll give me
a little bit of help
with your "algorithms."
Right. You're not using
an archaic spreadsheet.
I'm gonna pay you $99 a month
for access to that?
Right.
You want--
I hate that business.
I'm out.
Okay.
Well, Bill, I'm glad that Mark
explained it to me as well,
because if it was that hard
for you to explain it to me,
it's gonna be
that much harder
for you to explain
to customers,
and that pitch was underwater.
I'm out.
I buy a lot
of foreclosed property
in my local market,
because I understand it,
and I have access to brokers
who have great information.
They have certain information
that is on no web site.
I don't think you can possibly
think of a formula
that will lead me
to the right conclusion
that this is a great investment
or it's not a great investment.
But you do have one
great thing going for you.
Nobody can tell
if you're wrong. (laughs)
No one's gonna know
if you're ever right,
because the only time
you find out whether you
indicated a great investment
or not
is when I go to sell it
in two years,
five years, eight years.
And where are you gonna be then?
I'm out.
Thank you.
Bill, you have
no business concept.
You talk out of
both sides of your mouth.
I'm gonna build this company
to a $100 million Company
right next to zillow.
(Robert) Bill, there's nothing
wrong with believing that.
But the presentation
you came up with today
made you appear like
a bit of a con artist.
I'm not a s--
I'm out.
You're getting your ass
kicked in here.
I-I know.
And, you know, I always
respect somebody
that comes out of
financial services,
'cause it's a very tough space.
And the one
you've come out of
was a really tough space.
So you're trying
to get back in the game.
Nothing wrong with that,
but won't be with me. I'm out.
Thank you.
Everybody's out?
Bill, you gotta leave now
before it gets better.
Okay. Thank you. (laughs)
(laughs)
(Daymond) He reminded me of you,
Barbara.
(laughs)
He wasn't
a dishonest guy.
He just didn't present well.
Did he leave
with an extra orifice?
(laughs)
the answer is "Yes."
(Bill) I clearly blew it
out there. It was brutal.
It was like I walked
into a wood chipper.
♪♪♪
(horse whinnies)
(nickers)
I'm Beverly Vines-Haines.
And I'm Charlotte Clary,
and we're from
Yelm, Washington.
Whoo!
We've been friends
26 years.
And between the two of us,
we have...
(both) 37 grandkids.
You'd think 37 grandchildren
would keep us busy enough,
but while all our friends
are out
scrapbooking and quilting,
we've developed
a major business.
♪♪♪
Things are so busy
at the factory,
we now have both our husbands
working here with us.
Mmm! Still my favorite.
We also want
our grandchildren
to learn the value
of hard work,
so we are happy
to put them to work
as soon as they get
old enough.
It is definitely
a family business.
So you want a full set
of every flavor?
Now that we've got
all this business,
we cannot keep
hand-crafting our product.
To get to the level we want
to get to, we need the sharks.
A deal with the sharks
would be
amazing for
the entire family.
♪♪♪
Hi. I'm Bev Vines-Haines.
And I'm Charlotte Clary,
and we're the founders
of Ice Chips candy.
We're asking for $250,000
in exchange for a 15% equity
in our company.
In the competitive
candy and mint world,
xylitol is the hottest
alternative sweetener going.
Ice chips are
the yummiest, healthiest
xylitol candy on the market.
Most sugar-free candy
and "healthy" candy
tastes like petrified flour.
But our candy comes
in 17 exciting flavors--
Zesty, stimulating,
and actually good
for adults and children.
It's true.
Xylitol is
a natural sweetener.
Germs and bacteria
cannot grow on it,
so dentists love it.
Life still hands out
plenty of surprises.
We thought by this time
we would be doing
grandma things
for our 37 grandchildren.
Wow.
Whoa.
But, no,
we're taking orders,
shipping ice chips,
and negotiating prices
all over the world.
We may have started out
as two grannies in a garage...
(laughs)
But believe me,
we've grown
far beyond that now.
And all we had to give up
was the thrilling life
of scrapbooking and quilting
many of our friends enjoy.
(laughter)
Not.
Not!
(laughter)
Now we'd like you
to try our ice chips.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Thank you, Charlotte.
Thank you.
Kevin, Beverly says
she thinks
she used to babysit you.
(laughter)
Tastes great.
Mmm.
Doesn't taste sugar-Free.
(Robert) So, ladies,
xylitol is all natural?
It's not chemically made?
Absolutely natural.
Yes.
Hmm.
I've never seen
this type of candy.
Health food stores are
our primary source for sales.
Dentists sell them.
A lot of them sell them
in their offices.
We use American xylitol
made from the Birch bark
of the Birch tree.
Any downside
to that chemical?
It's something
I'm not familiar with.
Any side effect?
Only if you eat
the whole tin.
Yeah. Then there can be...
(laughs)
a little tummy distress--
If you ate the whole tin.
Tummy distress?
What would that be?
Diarrhea.
(Daymond and Barbara) Oh.
Oh.
(laughing)
(Daymond) It's not
like a laxative.
I'm just trying to get
clarity.
Oh, no, no, no.
Not like a laxative.
All right, you guys can
continue to eat them then.
You're a couple of grannies
on steroids. I get it.
(laughing)
You're valuing
your ice chips business
at $1.67 million.
Yes.
That's quite a bit.
Explain to me why you think
it's worth that much money.
This year,
up through Friday,
our sales for ice chips
was $342,000.
Really?
Yes.
Last year,
sales were $360,000.
Wow. Charlotte,
that's fantastic.
Sales--
So we've almost doubled.
Oh, so you're halfway through.
Yes.
So you think you'll hit,
uh, $700,000 this year.
$700,000.
We actually think
we could hit
that million-Dollar mark
by the end of the year.
Those are some sweet numbers.
(both laugh)
What are you making it for
and what are you selling it for?
We make it right now
for $1.11 a tin.
It wholesales for
$3 and 12 1/2 cents a tin.
(Daymond) nice.
The average sale
in a store is $5.
Are you opening more accounts,
or are the same accounts
just increasing their orders?
Yes and Yes.
Nice.
We have about
ten new accounts--
10 to 12 new accounts
every week.
Why is it shaped like flakes?
The honest answer?
No, I want you to lie
to me, granny.
(both laugh)
Two grannies in a garage
couldn't press out
100,000 little pellets.
(Beverly) Yeah.
(Robert) Come on, seriously?
So you just hit it
with a hammer? Bang?
Serious.
Yep. Yes.
But they said
you couldn't make hard candy
from xylitol,
and we did what they said
couldn't be done.
And by pouring it
and then breaking it this way
and calling it ice chips,
everyone has loved it.
(laughs)
Tell me your background
before you became grannies.
Well,
I was a romance writer.
So probably not gonna
help you much.
(laughter)
I have a bachelor of science
degree in natural health.
(Daymond) There's other candies
in the market.
I-I just want to know
about your competitors.
Spry is our biggest competitor,
'cause dentists also do them.
But they have
a pressed candy, like...
what other pressed candy?
Like an altoid?
Maybe Altoids is pressed.
Yeah. And are these sold
only in, uh, mainly, uh,
health food stores,
or are they in 7-Elevens
and Walgreens and...
Well, that's distribution.
It's hard to get in.
We do have
a lot of grocery stores.
We're in grocery--
But there's a distributor
you want to sell to
that's gonna supply all them.
(Beverly and Charlotte) Yes.
(Daymond) So you guys--
You have everything.
You know, you know your market,
you know your numbers.
You're making money.
So why are you here?
Automation.
To bring our margin down
where we make this for 77 cents.
Basically want us
to buy you a machine
that's gonna cost
$250,000, right?
Yes.
Well--
$250,000--That's not even
$5,000 per grandchild.
Get those grandchildren
out there working.
That's true.
Get them to make
a few thousand bucks,
and you're good to go.
We are.
We have two of them
working there now.
(both laugh)
I'd like to make you
an offer.
What I like best
about the product
over all of the candy products
I've seen, dietary or not,
is I love the idea
that you have chips.
You can pick how big
or little a chip
you want to pop in your mouth.
I don't know why, but I love,
like, picking it out.
(laughing)
Like a choice.
(Mark) Yeah, you're right.
(Barbara) You know?
That's unique.
And I would just like
to go on a sales call with you,
just to see what you do.
You're a hoot.
(laughing)
So it would be three grandmas.
Whatever. No problem.
The full granny gang.
If you wanna call me
a grandma, no problem.
So I'm gonna give you
half the investment--$125,000.
But I'll have to have
more stock.
I would need 1/3 of the business
for that--33%.
Ohh! That's crazy.
For just your piece?
Yes, for just my piece.
So, Barbara,
they have to go out and raise
the other $125,000,
and get another 33%.
You're a vicious granny.
♪♪♪
Beverly and Charlotte
have one partial offer
on the table,
from Barbara.
But she wants
a whopping 33% of the company
for just her half
of the investment.
You're a vicious granny.
I-I--
I'm not vicious at all.
Ladies, what else
is in this candy?
(Barbara) Hold on. Hold on.
Finish, Barb. Finish, Barb.
Please, please, please.
(laughs)
What I guarantee you--
as part of the offer--
is that I'll get you
in 3,000 big box stores
to sell your product.
Ooh. Interesting.
And that's worth
a lot of money.
Would you feel free
to take out your dentures
and throw it at her...
(laughing)
For that rude
and insensitive offer?
What is wrong with that?
How long would it take you
to get into all those
big box stores?
Not long.
Grannies, I want to put
the other half up
that Barbara needs, and you
get something else from me.
I'm gonna talk her back
into sanity on value.
So what I'm gonna say is this--
I'll put up the other
$125,000,
and we will each get
20% each.
So we're taking 40%,
not 66%.
You know what?
I will retrench a bit
on that value,
but not with this guy.
He's no fun to work with.
He's totally focused
on money,
and you both know
it's not about the money.
You need somebody
like Mr. Wonderful
in the model.
Trust me, you don't need him.
So I'll do that deal. Any other
guys wanna do that deal?
No problem.
But not with this guy.
So I'll do $125,000 for 20%,
because I must say,
I did feel a little bit greedy.
Look at the value I've
created for you already.
I took her down
from being insane,
asking for 66%.
(Daymond) Well, I'm--I'm--
I'm interested.
My only concern is
I don't want, uh, you guys
to be doing the manufacturing.
I don't want to have to learn
that part of the business.
So what I'd be interested in
is $250,000 for...
30%,
and we go out and take
the manufacturing elsewhere.
Do we have any other offers?
Solid?
Patience is a virtue.
(laughs)
(Daymond)
I'm the only full offer.
You have half offers
from Kevin and Barbara.
Well, Barbara doesn't want
to play in this candy box.
And these savages
want to take 40%
of your company.
I-I delivered so much value
to the grannies,
and I'm getting nothing for it.
I'm really heartbroken.
We're smiling at you pretty,
if that helps. (laughs)
It helps.
I'm interested in working
with Barbara,
because I think she works really
well with consumer products.
I see a lot of ways
that we can work together.
So I'm happy to go in
with Barbara
at $125k for 20%,
and $125k for 20%.
You know, when I put out
my offer,
I was hoping
Mark would jump in with me.
There's no better partner here.
(inhales)
Ladies, it--
It's sweeter than I would
have offered you.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Okay, grannies,
let's shake it up a bit.
I want back in this deal.
Okay, so here's what
I'm gonna propose.
I want to join Daymond.
So he'll put up $125,000.
I'll put up $125,000.
So you get your $250,000.
But I want to be part
of a 35% deal.
All right?
But you get two sharks.
And it's still way less
than what Barbara and Mark
are asking for.
They're so greedy.
Ooh! So, grandmas...
(Daymond) I think--
Yeah, I think, uh...
grandmas, you--
That might sweeten the deal.
Uh, if you have two sharks
here for less percentage.
So, grandmas,
Kevin and Daymond,
or Mark and Barbara?
The sweet deal,
or the yuck mouths?
The vindictive deal,
or the honest deal?
We know.
Oh, you do? Wow.
(Daymond)
I've decided that--
(Kevin) What--
I've decided that I-I'm
dropping my partner already...
Oh.
And I'm going down--
Whoa, everything
changes in the tank!
And I'm going down
to 25% for $250,000.
(Robert and Mark) WHOA!
Whoa!
Daymond, what happened there?
Your offer is $250,000
for 25%...
(Kevin) Whoa.
But you, just like Barbara,
are dumping Kevin to the curb.
I'm dumping Kevin.
The only reason why
is because I feel this
Barbara crap growing on them,
and I want to make sure
that they don't make
the wrong decision.
So, what are you gonna do?
You can tell.
Okay.
We're gonna go
with Barbara and Mark.
Ahh!
Good decision.
Yes!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Smart people.
You picked the good people.
I never liked grandmothers.
Don't be mean to grandma.
Bye.
Thanks, ladies.
(Charlotte)
We so appreciate them all,
but we just really felt
the Barbara/Mark combination,
for our personality,
was probably gonna be the best.
Business-wise,
a different decision
might be good,
but personality-wise,
we will...
be happy.
Kill it together.
(laughs)
listen, I can go to bed
knowing I helped granny.
Talk about judging a book
by its cover.
They're hustlers.
This is something
that Barbara will enjoy.
They will love to get
on the phone with her
and hear her ramble about
her cockamamie stories
for, like, two weeks.
(laughs)
I loved the grandmas.
I love the gramas, too,
and I hate--UGH!
♪♪♪